and he had two things against him he was
black animus the black man in this
country is an endangered species
[Music]
if the bottom line is there was reckless
endangerment
see the young man the victim was
surrounded by five police officers and
FBI and they approached him in a rave a
wreck reckless manner at a shopping
early in the morning with school buses
and pedestrians and cars would that be
the best way they knew where they lived
they suspected that he was dangerous why
would they do this out in the open you
know what we find it's going on with the
black men in America if you can't
incarcerate them in an island they
wanted him alive he'd be alive today so
this whole thing this is a mess and it's
cost the life of a young American boy
just 26 years old and probably didn't
make the best of decisions I don't think
that the warrants in his death he didn't
take anybody's life and if he was
threatening to take somebody's life and
they wanted to apprehend him I mean most
assuredly couldn't very easily of
something my impression of him was that
he was impressionable if what he had
the media had him to think that he that
the woman down there who was drawing
pictures of a prophet that they don't
even know they're there insulting
behavior himself to them not in that
Prophet Muhammad there's an old
expression that we have an American
sticks and stones will break my bones
but your names will never hurt me so we
have to take a higher ground unless we
get caught up in the muck and mire of
their diatribe
[Music]